political satire is now impossible I
have just returned from Washington DC I
was there for 24 hours I was there
talking to the Attorney General of the
United States which we will get to a
little bit later in the show and while I
was there the rioters the peaceful
protesters promised to tear down in the
name of racial justice a statue of the
Emancipation Proclamation
that freed the slaves yes this famous
statue in Washington DC the Emancipation
Proclamation statue is one of Abraham
Lincoln and a freed slave it was paid
for in 1876 by black people recently
freed to honor the man who freed them to
honor their freedom and now that statue
to freedom is considered racist they are
tearing it down here are the geniuses
who want to pull down our history our
team members out here we don't want to
tear down the statue today we don't want
to do the day we are going to be doing
it on Thursday at 7:00 p.m. okay
Thursday at 10:00 p.m. cest birthday
[Applause]
just an odd lease on the side going to
blacklivesmatter Plaza no no we're not
doing that no more we are going to show
up and wake these rich white people up
gonna wake those rich white people you
know rich white people like Abraham
Lincoln now Thursday at 7 p.m. came and
went as you might imagine the rioters
are not the most reliable people on
earth but they still plan to pull down
the statue
DC's fake congressman representative
eleanor holmes norton has called for the
Statue to come down DC's mayor has
suggested the statue might come down but
we can't pretend any longer that this is
about police brutality or systemic
racism or about the Confederacy or for
the slaves because right now we're
talking about a statue of the guy who
freed the slaves who beat the
Confederacy the anarchists are targeting
the most ironic man they're making it
explicitly about race and ironically all
that could do is gin up racial tensions
we'll get into it I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the Michael Noel's show
it is good to be back here in la-la land
after a whirlwind trip to DC where I
like to credit my presence there for
delaying the tear down of the
Emancipation Proclamation statue I have
no evidence that that is true but but
look it's a coincidence and so clearly
there's something there but before we
get into that because there's a a racial
point here that I think that the the
anarchists and the radicals who defend
them are completely missing and it's
pretty ironic but first the question I
asked on our last show was should Trump
use force on the Chaz Choppers and the
best comment came from no thanks
who said Trump should definitely use
force at the very least we need a
presence in Somalia we can call it mega
D shoe so a good point although
unfortunately Chaz may be going the way
of the dodo which we will get to in one
moment first also I have to thank our
friends over at quip you know your
routines over the past few weeks and
months have probably gotten a little
wonky they've gone up and down time
seems to have stood still but hopefully
one habit that didn't go away is
brushing your teeth it's an important
one and the quip electric toothbrush has
timed sonic vibrations with 30-second
pulses to guide a dentist recommended 2
minute routine there's even a size down
version designed for kids
paired with quip Santi cavity toothpaste
in mint or watermelon you get all the
ingredients teeth actually need and none
that they don't it's very important to
have an electric toothbrush I used to
have the old old-fashioned kind which
basically is just a stick rubbing
against your teeth you got to get an
electric toothbrush equipped also has an
eco-friendly refillable floss and with a
dispenser that you keep for life an
expanding string that helps to clean in
between quick brush a toothpaste floss
refills are automatically delivered on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five dollars each you're
not gonna beat that five dollars each
and shipping is free joint over 3
million happy customers if you were to
get quipped gum slash Michael right now
you will get your first refill for free
that is your first refill free at get
quip dot-com slash Michael get Q UIP
um slash michel quip the good habits
company obviously that rioter who talked
about pulling down the Emancipation
Proclamation statue is speaking in
explicitly racial terms because he also
was rallying everyone to go show up to
Mitch McConnell's house and other people
he said we're gonna keep these rich
white people up it's all about white
white white and obviously now we they
can no longer say that it's about
tearing down statues of slavers because
Abraham Lincoln freed the slaves they
can't say it's about tearing down I
don't know the Confederate flag because
you're talking about the man who saved
the Union it's a white thing for a lot
of people and that is true even of a
lecturer at Cambridge University who
tweeted out abolish whiteness this
lecturers name is priyamvada Gopal a lot
of people have reported her because
imagine if you said abolish Mexicans
abolish blackness by if you said those
things that that's I suppose threatening
it's at least wishing ill on a whole
group of people and so you would be
taken down Twitter the other day took
down a censored rather a tweet from
President Trump because he said he would
enforce the law against criminals he
said we're gonna use we're going to
enforce the law against criminals they
said this is violent it's threatening
harm to other people and yet abolish
whiteness stays up on Twitter and then
what's even crazier is the way that
Cambridge University reacted to the
tweet was to give this woman a promotion
she went from a lecturer to a full
professor which tells you just about
everything that you need to know about
the Academy but the tweet got me
wondering what is whiteness this is a
term that's come up among these radicals
abolish whiteness whiteness as toxic
well what is whiteness
I don't think about whiteness very much
when I think about how I identify in my
life
white is very low on the list what
constitutes my identity well I'm
Catholic I'm if we wanted to get
specific nationally I guess I'm of
Italian extract still don't think about
that as white a lot of people wonder if
Italians are white or a little bit
swarthy I think that I'm a New Yorker
was born in New York well I live in Los
Angeles now I'm an American obviously
that's way up there
on the list I'm a man that's way up
there on the list whiteness is very low
and I'm not the only one who thinks this
way it turns out white people have a
very low racial consciousness so a few
research did this survey in its the race
in America survey twenty nineteen and
they asked what percentage of each
groups say that being white or black or
Asian or whatever is extremely or very
important to how they think about
themselves so among among Asian people
its twenty seven percent say it's
extremely important to think of their
race 29 percent additionally say it's
very important so fifty six percent most
Asians say that their race is at least
very important to their identity among
Hispanics the number is 31% extremely
important twenty-eight percent very
importance of fifty nine percent say
their race is at least very important to
them among black people that number
jumps to seventy four percent total so
fifty fifty two percent most black
people say that their race is extremely
important to their identity an
additional twenty two percent say very
important bring it to 74 and then white
people do you know the number is just 15
total so 10 percent say it's very
important to their identity and just
five percent say it's extremely
important to their identity 15 percent
racial consciousness so ironically when
you have a tweet like abolish whiteness
what that actually has the effect of
doing is creating whiteness whiteness as
a concept is not one that's really
recognized by a lot of people
eighty-five percent of white people
probably wouldn't recognize that concept
and yet if we are constantly being told
you're white you're white that is your
identity and it's terrible and we
shouldn't have it there is no other
effect that that could have than to
create a racial consciousness now
perhaps that's the point because on the
one hand it's easy not to have a racial
consciousness if you're the majority
population in a country but I think
beyond that because in the West we have
this idea of anti racism we have the
idea that we're made in the image of God
that we have human solidarity come from
a common ancestor we just naturally have
a lower racial consciousness
I suspect the left is pushing this
because they want there to be a white
racial consciousness because they want
to pit racial groups against one another
and because liberalism seems to require
overcoming the oppressive past and
having a villain when there are no more
villains to have than you just have to
start making them up now that's the
ideological side of things how about the
practical side of things or these riots
still going to keep burning you know
they're making up an invisible villains
and invisible enemies at a certain point
you think that would burn out the be haz
the Black House autonomous zone in DC is
still running but the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone in Seattle it is no more
the dream of Chas chop is over a
statement from the chest chopped Twitter
account says quote few people remain in
our beloved chop the statement was
signed by the capitol hill occupied
protest solidarity committee and they
said very finely the chop project is now
concluded
no more chop it's very sad but that's
just the way that it goes it was always
ever it was as always ever thus
right it was always going to go away it
was a utopian project and like all
utopian projects it was disgusting it
was terrible it was violent people died
it destroyed property it destroyed the
rights of certain people yet the mayor
of Seattle who was tolerating this said
it was going to be the Summer of Love
I didn't look very much like the Summer
of Love now the Summer of Love has
fizzled out I think it went so quickly
because we're just moving on a faster
timeline here we're moving on a faster
news cycle we're moving on a faster
protest cycle we went from tearing down
robert e lee to tearing down statues of
saint Junipero Serra very quickly right
it began to tearing down any depiction
of Jesus that looks white according to
Sean King things are getting a little
bit faster and the bright side of that
is things like the Chazz will fizzle out
now speaking of fizzling out our good
and Joe Biden is still running for
president we'll get a little bit more
into the presidential election later but
let's not forget this man is still
running and he is losing more and more
of his consciousness every single day
they are trying to go back and gin up
this coronavirus idea well Joe Biden has
a scary number for you he is under the
impression that coronavirus has hit 120
million people already worldwide I just
got off the phone this morning with dr.
Vivek Murthy and he and and others who
he was a former Surgeon General and a
number of experts who work I have a
meeting hour and a half telephone
conference with them zoom conference
once a week I mean four times a week and
that's why we have a major multi-billion
dollar investment in mental health
well people drastically underestimated
is the impact on the mental health of
people who now everything is complicated
not only is the health care piece but
people don't have a job people don't
have anywhere to go they don't know what
they're going to do and a lot of people
you have unnecessarily now we have over
120 million dead from covent hundred I
mean 120 million dead you know it's
funny I actually have to correct myself
the first time I heard that clip I
thought he was saying over 120 million
cases worldwide which obviously is not
true know what he said it's even crazier
he's saying there's 120 million dead and
it seems he's implying in America which
is a country of 330 million people
that's a lot huh that's actually though
the number is not anywhere close to that
it's multiple orders of magnitude lower
than that watching or listening to Joe
Biden these days you have to think the
man is not up to the job and yet the
poll numbers show he's actually in a
pretty good position or the polls lying
possibly but does president Trump think
he's gonna sail to re-election I think
probably not we'll get into those
numbers in just a little bit first
though I got to thank our friends over
at wide foods oh my goodness wise foods
how much I love them our sponsor wise
company recently changed their name to
ready wise they are there for you to get
prepared during
and before an emergency well these days
probably we want to be a little more
prepared than usual with long-term
nutritional food options ready wise has
options like emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition new
adventure meals for hiking camping and
other outdoor activities ready wise
meals are easy to prepare you just add
water to them they have a very long
shelf life
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep most importantly they
taste good they use the finest
ingredients and latest food preparation
technology to ensure optimal taste and
freshness you cannot be too prepared
my friends this week my listeners get
free shipping at ready wise calm when
entering Noel's came to wles
at checkout or by calling eight five
five four five three twenty nine forty
five ready wise as a ninety day no
questions asked return policy there's no
risk taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family prepared today
that's ready wise Rea dy w ISE calm
promo code Knowles to get free shipping
now the corona virus is back according
to Joe Biden under twenty million dead
in America obviously nowhere near that
but still this is the message that's
being sent to everybody coronavirus is
back we've all got to worry but what
about the past few weeks where the
public health officials and the
politicians have been encouraging people
to go out not social distance be around
hundreds of thousands of other people
the Seattle autonomous zone is the
Summer of Love what about all of that
clearly there is a political agenda at
work here if the virus is SuperDuper
deadly dangerous stay in your house wear
a mask one minute and then when it's
advantageous to the left they say no big
deal go out and protest for whatever
racial or social issue you want to well
they're back on it shamelessly and they
want you to know that the reason the
corona virus is spiking has nothing to
do with the protest it's almost it's
almost hilarious if it weren't so
corrupt it would be hilarious that at
this point they actually have headlines
like this in NPR parties not protests
are causing spikes in coronavirus
parties so those scenes that you've seen
for weeks now of hundreds of thousands
of people together that has
thing to do with coronavirus but when
you go over and have dinner with your
friend that is what's causing the spike
in coronavirus you remember the public
health officials to 1200 of the middle
east signed a petition that said that
you should encourage the protests
because white supremacy is a public
health issue that is causing coronavirus
to spike i kid you not and social
justice protests sjw radical BLM
protests will actually help reduce the
spread of coronavirus based on what
based on the science I guess another
article this one just came out yesterday
black lives matter protests haven't led
to co vid spikes it may be due to people
staying home oh that's why we're getting
a spike as people are staying home all
right then lift the lockdown workers
they're probably not gonna support that
either all they want to do though is
protect BLM or an tyfa or the Chazz job
zone that all they want to do is protect
anything that can hurt Trump and they
will not permit any of that to lift for
the next five months it is all about the
presidential election and the sad thing
is it may be working
I mean even just look the next time they
bring up the masks to you I just a word
to the wise point to Denmark point to
Finland point to Norway
point to Sweden all of which governments
are advising against wearing the masks
in public but the masks as we know have
become a political symbol Joe Biden he
was giving a speech were the masks
dangling from his ear wasn't covering
his face or wasn't preventing the spread
of the virus but he couldn't take it
down because now he's telling everyone
they have to wear the mask you're just
dangling from his ear that's the
political symbol it's incoherent
obviously the headlines are ridiculous
and yet I think it might be working
because a quote of neck warm Oh Biden's
numbers are actually up fairly high so
according to a New York Times Siena
College poll that came out on Thursday
Joe Biden is opening up a wide lead in
important States particularly Michigan
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin Biden leads
those states by double digits now do I
believe the polls
not really I don't but we can see some
frustration among Trump supporters
because the riots have been allowed to
carry on without very much in the way of
consequences
though the Attorney General says
consequences are coming which we'll get
to in a little bit the economy obviously
we threw 40 million people out of work
over this lockdown which now seems to be
based on completely bunk science so am I
worried that if the election were held
today Trump would lose all those states
not necessarily but I am worried in
general that if if the president doesn't
turn something around if the president
doesn't change his messaging a little
bit if the president doesn't show hard
results and a return to law and order
he's gonna have trouble in November
because all of the media complex
everything is geared against him just on
this example of the coronavirus consider
how they are covering the corona virus
so Andy Cuomo governor of New York has
handled this worse than any governor in
America New York got hit the worst they
dealt with it the worst they had no idea
how to keep their hospitals open they
had no idea they had to call in the
federal government for that they had no
idea how many ventilators they needed
then they got it wrong the first time on
it on they had to a few then they had
too many they then sent sick people into
nursing homes the most vulnerable
population killed thousands of elderly
New Yorkers I mean it's just been a
bungled disaster and the fault lies at
the feet of Governor Andrew Cuomo but
you wouldn't know that if you watch the
mainstream media because the coverage
he's getting is on a television show
hosted by his brother on CNN watch the
Cuomo lovefest take a listen everything
that he ever said mattered to him about
public service is what you demonstrated
right here and right now during this
period when your state needed it most
and I hear it all the time not everybody
likes you not everybody likes me
everybody seems to like pop now that's
the benefit of being out for a while
maybe done I just hope you recognize
what even I'm able to recognize being
spawned from the same wolf pack I hope
you are able to appreciate what you did
in your state and what it means for the
rest of the country now and what it will
always mean to those who love and care
about you the most
I'm wowed by what you did and more
importantly I'm wild by how you did it
this was very hard I know it's not over
but
obviously I love you as a brother
obviously I'll never be objective
obviously I think you're the best
politician in the country but I hope you
feel good about what you did for you
people cuz I know they appreciate it
they don't appreciate it they don't like
it because what you did is kill people
unnecessarily through very stupid
policies he he did just consider this in
the same interview and equal moe attacks
the governor of Florida Republican
governor of Florida and says that he
gambled on the virus and he lost New
York has ten times as many coronavirus
deaths as Florida ten times Florida
reopened early New York did not they've
been playing this up in the press is
what a great job Andy Cuomo did Cuomo's
response to the virus led to more deaths
than the Republican response in Florida
it doesn't that's not the way it's going
to be played if they can lie as brazenly
as all that consider how the rest of the
election season is going to play out
Trump has got to get on top of this
messaging it tends to be his strength I
mean that's why he uses Twitter but now
Twitter is censoring him right he uses
Twitter to speak directly the American
people will now big tech is gonna shut
that down to everything about the deck
of this election is stacked against
President trumpet he's got to get
tougher on his messaging otherwise how
do you stand up to these corrupt
institutions meanwhile they they pretend
to be moderate they pretend to be the
reasonable people here Andy Cuomo was
asked on NBC News what he thought about
the riders tearing down all of these
statues and I kid you not with a
straight face he said that ripping down
statues roving mobs of anarchists is a
healthy expression of political opinion
the Teddy Roosevelt statue I think was
less about that Teddy Roosevelt but the
the other parts of that of that statue
and look people are making a statement
about equality about community to be
against racism against slavery I think
those are good statements and it depends
you know
you overdo it of course you can but in
New York I don't think we've overdone it
and I think that I think it's a healthy
expression of people saying let's get
some priorities here and let's remember
the sin and mistake that these this
nation made and let's not celebrate it a
healthy expression I like that he uses
the phrase healthy too because they tell
us specifically on the question of
health if you go outdoors you're gonna
get coronavirus and it's gonna kill you
and kill everyone around you but when
you're gathering to tear down statues
that's healthy and obviously on the
metaphorical sense it's not healthy
either as a country to just roam around
and rip down your own history to hate
yourself as a nation and to destroy
property nothing about that is healthy
but what he does is he equates tearing
down statues with opposing racism and
opposing slavery let me ask you
something
how many people do you know these days
who are pro-slavery but you know they've
got bumper stickers and one of the
bumper stickers is I support slavery
bring back slavery at nobody nobody is
pro-slavery and yet it's this rhetorical
sleight of hand he's saying look they're
making this bold statement this brave
courageous statement that they oppose
racism and slavery and so we've got to
let them make that expression it's the
same thing we've been talking about for
a long time which is they have to set up
fake villains early on they said that
all these riots all this mayhem it's
being caused by white supremacists how
many white supremacists are there in
America like three we went through the
numbers very few people have any sort of
white racial consciousness at all and I
think the only people wearing Klan hoods
anymore and well actually they're
Democrat governor of Virginia I guess he
would be one we have photographic
evidence of that not that it it caused
his reputation to be canceled at all but
they have to invent this imaginary enemy
and so that's what Cuomo does with a
straight face yeah you know we're the
brave few who opposed slavery and racism
the implication being by the way that if
you oppose the tactics of these
anarchists and Marxists then you support
slavery and you support racism that's
the way it is so they'll cancel us grant
they'll cancel who free who won the war
that freed the slaves they'll cancel
Abraham Lincoln the president who freed
the slaves they'll cancel say
Junipero Serra they'll cancel Jesus
himself
okay they'll cancel all of these people
now the canceled culture is have any
effect beyond this there was a person
that I had never heard of until
yesterday who is one of the most
prominent youtubers her name is jenna
Marbles and a very important stuff
jenna Marbles jenna Marbles has a
YouTube channel of 20 million people
20 million subscribers she's been around
making videos for now for ten years and
they're just kind of funny videos
well she's quitting now she's quitting
the whole thing because people are
digging up old videos of hers that she
had deleted where I guess she told some
jokes that she now thinks her offensive
and they're trying to ruin her
reputation ten years after the fact
after they were deleted here is her
tearful goodbye and I don't want to put
anything out in the world that's gonna
hurt anybody
so I need to be done with this channel
for now or forever I don't know so
alright good talk
see you guys Miss marbles is apparently
such a prominent youtuber that she
actually has a statue at Madame Tussauds
Museum although certainly that statue at
this point all the statues are coming
down and especially that one of her that
line she says I don't want to put
anything out in the world that hurts
anybody this is the problem what we are
now being told is that if you if a
person has done anything bad ever
anything that is not perfect that is
grounds to tear down the statue but
consider the argument in all of these
shootings and on all the shootings that
allegedly led to the protests Candis
Owens got in a lot of trouble because
she pointed out that the media haven't
told the whole story about some of these
officer-involved killings and and that
in some cases the people who were killed
had a long criminal rap sheet maybe they
were committing crimes at the moment
that they were killed the response to
that the popular response is how dare
you bring up that person's past that
person's past has nothing to do with
what happened in that moment and we
shouldn't judge a man based on the bad
things that he did in his life even even
if they've done years and years of long
terrible things beat their wife abused
their kids we can't judge them for any
of that we should only judge them on
their their few best moments and yet
this
statue argument the cancel culture
argument is doesn't matter how much good
you do in your life if you've committed
one or two bad things that's what you
should be judged by the double standard
is absurd and it's obviously incoherent
but we are long past the stage of making
finely tuned arguments this is about
brute political force this is about an
ideological group clubbing everybody on
the head for their own interests whether
their arguments make any sense that
isn't the point this is a bare-knuckle
brawl at least until November and I
think unfortunately one side of this is
gonna go wishy-washy and buy into the
the lying premises of guys like Andrew
Cuomo and the anarchists and the valid
admitted Marxists who are running bln
and they'll say well I just don't want
to hurt anybody please don't come after
me I'll quit we can't quit folks we
can't quit this is the fight we're in it
now and you can either stand up and and
fight that fight and hopefully preserve
America before they tear the whole thing
down preserve American solidarity before
they divide us up completely or you can
surrender well that's it luckily I sat
down with a fighter yesterday in two
days ago in Washington DC I was there
for 24 hours and as part of my show with
senator Cruz verdict we sat down with
the man the myth the legend the Attorney
General of the United States William bar
take a listen to a quick part of our
conversation senator you have brought a
friend Thank You mr. Attorney General
for being here you know the news broke
just moments ago that you will testify
before the House Judiciary Committee
next month so we are honored that you
would sit down with us first and very
much appreciate it I want to get right
into this obviously there's so much
going on and it occurs to me we have a
man who writes the laws we have the man
who enforces the laws and we have
popular calls for utter lawlessness in
the country how do we restore order well
it's gonna it's going to take both state
and local government as well as federal
government the federal government is
best positioned to address this kind of
violence and lawlessness after it occurs
because we don't have FBI agents walking
the beat
and in fact when when the real violence
started around May 25th 6:00 and so
forth we started using our joint
terrorist task forces around the country
and that there 35 of them around the
country it involves all state and local
in those jurisdictions and all the
federal agencies and it's the system we
designed to follow terrorists and now
they are starting to go full-bore
cranking out investigations indictments
against the people who are involved in
this violence so we've we've had scores
of indictments already from for such
things as arson destruction of federal
property things like that and we have
right now about 500 investigations
underway so it's picking up pace and we
are committed to holding accountable the
people who are engaged in this but we
still have to try to stop it before it
happens and that's where the burden is
right now on state and local and in many
places they're not stepping up to the
plate there they're not doing their job
so I know it's early but but how much
indications are y'all saying of
coordination and planning rather than
spontaneous acts of violence right we
are we are seeing a strong evidence of
coordination and many of these violent
episodes fundamentally what you have
here is you have demonstrators some of
them go there with the intent of
demonstrating but you have a group of
provocateurs and agitators sometimes a
significant group they try to convert
those into violent activity and they
seem to be very well coordinated when
they show up a number of Myr sociated
with the movement called Hannity feh but
they go by various names but frequently
and artistic they want to tear down the
country the there different than many
traditional groups and and frequently
the signs of coordination and activity
are very close to the event itself so
like the morning of or the day before
and things are very fast moving but we
definitely see signs out on the street
of communication of organization
of pre-planning pre positioning of
things so it's definitely organized act
well if if you're calling in that
terrorism task force
that means presumably that we're dealing
with terrorism here I know the president
came out and said just a couple of days
ago that this will not be tolerated on
federal land you cannot destroy federal
property and he's authorizing the
government to go and hold people
accountable what will this mean in terms
of a change of policy or an acceleration
of a policy that was already in place
well is it it's not it's not a change in
policy in the sense that we've always
had the obligation is the federal
government to protect federal facilities
and federal landmarks and monuments and
so forth but now because in some places
the local police are not doing an
adequate job we're going to have to step
up the federal effort to do that and so
that there are two aspects to it
obviously we're going to prosecute right
now all the videos involved in the
attack on the president Jackson's
statute are being carefully reviewed and
we will go after people so if you attack
a monument on federal property you're
going to get prosecuted that's right
yeah
but we're also in and and the the
criminal statute has serious jail time I
know that n years 10 years yep
and the other thing is we have to do a
better job of trying to stop these
groups when they before they are able to
do damage to these monuments and said
it's fine to punish them afterward but I
think a lot of us would like the statues
to remain up we spent another probably
half an hour or so with attorney general
Barr he got into some real specifics on
not just the riots and what's happening
and how many people are being indicted
but he got into big tech what the
administration is doing to combat big
tech and what we can expect in the next
few weeks he got into Obama gate he got
into some of the politicization of the
DOJ before he took office and senator
Cruz gave bill Barr a nickname he so go
check out that I won't I won't tell you
any more than that but go check out the
episode on verdict which is called bill
Barr is the honey badger
so thanks so much for getting our Michal
Knowles Show YouTube channel way up
there in the subscriptions we are nearly
going to pass a hundred thousand we will
do that with your help so thanks I
appreciate you checking out the daily
wire YouTube channel but then you know
it Ben doesn't need all those views head
on over to the Michael Nolt show YouTube
channel we got a lot of fun bonus
content and interviews and things like
that if you're not already a daily Y
remember you should consider getting a
reader's pass to daily wire.com great
value just three bucks a month for the
first month my gift to you
it is only 99 cents you'll get access to
our mobile app articles ad free access
to exclusive editorials like this one
which one is this this from Christian
tota great writer great write around
Hollywood - and toda has an article up
now just for daily wire members Fallon
Kimmel and stern here's the naked truth
behind canceled culture gives you real
insider view into Hollywood from a
conservative perspective we have so many
other pieces back there from a lot of
different other writers so head on over
daily wired I come slash subscribe we'll
be right back with the mailbag
all right first question from James hi
Michael I've heard a lot of people say
statues coming down don't erase history
read a book what are your thoughts on
this Thanks this is an excuse made by
people who are trying to rewrite history
so it's true as long as you're not
burning books which is gonna be the next
thing that they try to do they're
already rewriting historical books and
they're already kicking many books off
of curricula and already banning books
from schools but let's say it were true
let's say you could read the history in
the book that's all well and good but
very few people read books something
like only 30% of Americans read a book
at all last year so when you say that
what you're really saying is ok if you
want if you have this silly little
preference of wanting to know the facts
about your country's history that's fine
but don't stop us from rewriting it
because for most people seeing statues
seeing monuments is how we really live
our history it's how we acknowledge our
history as a country think about it in
say the Middle Ages when many people
could not read and when books were so
expensive that many people did not have
access to the Bible the way that you
would see the faith and understand the
faith would be through statues and icons
iconography stained-glass windows right
works of art that's how you could
experience it and see it and take it in
even if you couldn't read a single word
it's the same way that we understand
ourselves as a country when we knock
those things down then we knock down the
history itself we knock down what is
important regardless of your modern
feelings of being offended by looking at
a Confederate statue the Civil War is a
very important part of our history there
is a lot for us to learn it's a lot for
us to learn how we got into the Civil
War how we got out of the Civil War and
what the people who won the Civil War
told us we should think about it
suggested that we think about it and
when you tear down those statues you
lose all of that sort of thing what it's
really about is an antipathy for the
past because the past constrains
radicals who want to rewrite the future
and of course it they've put us in a
ridiculous position because they've said
why don't you want us to smash statues
say that's not the question that I
the burden of argument is on you the
people who want to smash the statues
smashing statues is not a normal thing
to do it doesn't go in the normal course
of daily events it's a radical change if
you want to affect it then you've got to
explain why you want to do it but they
won't tell you why and the real reason
is because they have a radical vision
for the future of the country and they
can't they can't affect it if they are
constrained by the past from Andrew have
you or your fellow daily wire hosts or
contributors and all joined or
considered joining parlor parlor I think
it would be nice if you and your hosts
did join in order to bring a larger
audience to the platform and challenge
the likes of Twitter why not give it a
shot
Thanks you know I actually did join
parlor yesterday I joined it because
first of all they're gonna kick us all
off of Twitter soon enough and they're
currently censoring the duly elected
president of the United States on
Twitter so I started a parlor the
trouble is because it's noon it's just
getting started I realized it was a fake
account pretending to be me it wasn't
like a parody account it was actually a
guy just pretending to be me so I think
parlor is getting rid of him but if you
want if you're done parlor and you want
to start following me I'm just at
Michael J Knowles J is important there
that's and the real one and I'll
probably post a few things on over there
but this doesn't solve the problem of
big tech censorship because the issue
with big tech and we spoke about this
with AG bar is they have cornered the
market they are the public square and
they did it on a false pretense to false
pretenses one they pretended to be a
neutral platform rather than a publisher
that curates content and so that got a
lot of buy-in from people and a two they
said that this would be an open forum
for all sorts of ideas and then those
are those are distinct concepts but they
are related concepts and then when they
got a critical mass of people when they
became the public square then they
changed the rules but it was too late
that the whole point of social media the
whole reason you would go and use a
certain social media platform is because
everybody is there so once everybody is
there it's very difficult if not
impossible to get them to move to
another platform you know sometimes
people say oh Michael if you think that
that big tech has a monopoly that
they've cornered the market
don't forget about myspace remember when
everyone said that about my space my
space never cornered the market they
never
the kind of critical mass that Facebook
and Google and Twitter have they didn't
they had like funny little gifs and
there was mostly used by teenagers and
kids right
your mom was probably not on MySpace
your grandma was probably not on MySpace
and yet your mother a grandmother very
likely are on Facebook and possibly even
on Twitter they've cornered that market
so we we do need to use the legal
remedies available to us to stop them
from abusing their power and violating
the law which is what they are parlor
might be a good use and I stopgap in the
meantime but it doesn't excuse us from
going after big tech from Daniel why
hasn't Trump sold red magum asks yet
that's the best way to get Democrats to
give up the charade there'd be a
national announcement saying that masks
are useless and only racists and white
supremacists wear them checkmate not a
terrible idea except it does cut against
some of the argument here because the
mask itself has become a political
symbol and it's a political symbol for
the left I'm not saying masks are not
ever useful I mean I don't think they're
useful in the way that the left tells us
they're useful right now which is what
the left says is the whole point of the
mask is to stop other people from being
infected but their argument before was
that it stopped you from being infected
their argument before that was the masks
are totally useless so they keep
changing their story but I'm not saying
they don't have any uses there's a
reason why surgeons wear masks the
question is are they useful now in
stopping the spread of the virus well we
showed you those those facts at a
Scandinavia that showed that they don't
really seem to matter very much there
they don't seem to matter very much here
either they are merely a way to signal
your virtue is why Joe Biden wore one
dangling from his ear he didn't care if
it would affect his breathing he just
you just wanted to show everybody that
he's on the right team because he's
wearing the right symbol so even if you
put a Magga symbol on it very likely
that would still cut against your
argument now some people who are
especially vulnerable to the virus or
who are germaphobes or something like
that you can understand why they would
wear the mask regardless of their
political views but the left has
undeniably turned it into a political
symbol and so Trump probably can't sell
them from Xavier I'm Michael big fan of
your show I'm listening from Europe here
in Belgium
my grandparents lived in Belgium for a
while maybe they I've never been but
maybe I'll
visit now that I know we have one
Belgian listener I see that you
commented that the French Revolution was
the worst thing that happened well
that's not quite sure I said it was one
of the worst events in the history of
the world it was a bad thing if you know
it's definitely up there could you
explain to me a bit why I vaguely
remember my history class about this
period and louis xvi and other bourgeois
wasn't open-minded and friendly with the
people thanks for reading me have a nice
day I think I think I understood that's
funny as I read that I could like hear
it in an accent but thank you Xavier for
the question the French Revolution is
now taught in schools as a good event
it's the beginning of the modern world
and yet it was one of the worst events
in the history of the world the way it's
presented in school is that it overcame
an oppressive past and gave people
freedom freedom and equality and
fraternity and that's not really what
happened consider this at least over
three times as many people were killed
in one year of the terror of the French
Revolution as were killed in the entire
350 years of the Spanish Inquisition at
least three they might have been as much
as five times or even a little bit more
than five times as many where people
were killed the French Revolution is the
guillotine the French Revolution took
everything that came before it and
ripped it apart said all of the
inherited wisdom of the world is trash
they took down a statue of Our Lady in
Notre Dom put up the goddess of Reason
they created a religion of a reason of
secularism they rewrote all the
neighbourhoods in Paris and made them
finely-tuned
rationalist experiments they they redid
the entire calendar they thought that
they could create the world from scratch
on the promise of a rational utopia
because it would be so much better than
what came before it and what did that
lead to the guillotine it led to a far
worse far crueler society one of the
perhaps the worst social experiment ever
in history and a precursor to all of the
evils that we would see later in
modernity national socialism fascism
and communism finally though a little
bit of the old tradition crept back
through again turned out people weren't
quite as smart and rational as they all
thought that they were and that there
was something to learn from the
inherited tradition and much more to be
said about the French Revolution but we
do have to move on that's a just a
beginning at least from Matt a steel
religious podcaster and Lord of khofifah
I've heard you and Clavin refer to the
American Revolution as a conservative
revolution that's funny funny position
of that question can you elaborate on
what that means how can a revolution be
conservative also I've heard you say
that as American conservatives we're
defending a liberal tradition sort of
what does that mean and how can the
concept of a conservative revolution be
reconciled with defending a liberal
tradition thanks we're using these words
kind of broadly conservative and liberal
but the big difference here between the
American Revolution and the French
Revolution is the French Revolution
sought to destroy everything that came
before it an overturned Society entirely
the American Revolution did not the
American Revolution maintained most
aspects of the society that it had left
and it and it maintained its Anglo
tradition and that's why we have such a
special relationship with the United
Kingdom even still today that was not
the case when the the revolutionaries in
France overturned the old regime in
America they kept their way of life they
kept their institutions most of them
they kept their families they kept their
religion that they kept most of their
political ideas and their system of law
and government in France they did not
they overturned all of those things in
France and so the American Revolution is
far more conservative you could call it
a conservative revolution that's why
Edmund Burke defended the American
Revolution and opposed the French
Revolution in his most famous work
reflections on the revolution in France
which was the beginning in many ways of
modern conservative political philosophy
now in America we do have this liberal
tradition in the sense that some of the
prominent liberal thinkers impacted the
way that we thought about our government
now I think the effect of those liberal
thinkers has been overstated and so for
instance we're told that John Locke
basically created the American regime
I'm not totally convinced of that but it
does put American conservatives in kind
of a weird position in that in some ways
some of the tradition that we're
defending is somewhat liberal but the
way I think about it there was a writer
I think it might have been Patrick
Dineen who who described this problem
and the problem
is that we have this high-flying Lockean
liberal language in documents like
Declaration of Independence and yet we
had a very conservative society and
though I think it was Dineen but it was
one of these conservative writers whose
writing today described that as saying
that Americans in the Revolutionary era
talked like Locke ian's they talked like
liberal revolutionaries but they lived
like berkians they lived like
conservatives they didn't always preach
what they actually practiced and Alexei
de Tocqueville who wrote democracy in
America coming from France observing the
American Revolution and how that led to
our society in the 19th century he
describes this he said they have their
civic associations they have their
traditions they have their family they
have their religion things that
ultimately liberalism would come to
oppose the Americans still maintained
and you can you can see the breakdown of
American society the more we've come to
embody those rationalist ideological
liberal ideas and the the less that
we've come to live our own conservative
institutions probably the only way we're
gonna be able to get that back is if we
can rebuild those institutions and turn
down the ideology that's the battle
we've got right now in jazz and chopping
all the way to November will we stand up
or will we surrender I sure hope it's
the former I guess we're gonna have
something to say about which one it is
and then we can wait and see in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Knowles show see you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens assistant
director pavel Woodhouse key editor and
associate producer danny D'Amico audio
mixer robin fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen